what do you think about when you think  about us  you and i were just  but forever  just be with me always  and always  [Music]  just tell me hamilton  spend a minute  i hear you do the time traveling thing  you've never been jaunty  it's amazing the past doesn't just  belong to history books anymore now we  can live it touch it change it  you're like cavemen you and him fighting  over janine yeah well she's my wife she  was his wife first  he wants you back  he's going through time to make us never  happen  no one can make us not happen  [Music]  janine  i will find you  [Music]  tommy changed our timeline so we never  met  maybe i go back in time what if you go  back but you end up with a different  future  janine  honey  you all right  i'm starting to forget my wife i'm  starting to lose her nobody belongs to  anyone  [Music]  something's different and i can feel it  you and i were just  forever  you